okay
good evening members
first of all the emergency evacuation
announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion via your
nearest fire exit
the two fire exits through the partition
doors are currently not in use due to
ongoing works
therefore the fire exits are through the
main doors of the hall or the storeroom
adjacent to the stage
the far assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the foyer area
no members of the public
foreign
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting
when I invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing Loop and for the audio recording
these are all switched on and ready for
you to speak and will be unmuted by
officers so you do not need to adjust
them
please make sure that the microphone is
close to your mouth before speaking and
please speak clearly
members voting will be down on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands for and
then against
and will also ask for a show of hands
for those wishing to abstain from voting
that understood members
agenda item one
apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councilor Mrs Lauren Shaw
councilor high councilor Mrs Mason and
councilor cross
agenda item 2 substitute members
councilor Mrs Tony Carter will be
substituting for councilor Laureen Shaw
and councilor sharp will be substituting
for Council across
agenda item three
non-members attending
there are none
agenda item four minutes of the meeting
held on the 16th of November 2022.
members are the minutes agreed
agreed thank you
agenda item five
to receive Declarations of interests
are there any Declarations of Interest
members
nope
agenda item six
external quality assessment of the
combined internal audit service
members Mike Porter Chief order
executive will introduce the report
please thank you
um just as a bit of background to this
item
all public sector internal audit service
is required to open external assessment
every five years
Basildon had his own external assessment
undertaken in January 2022 and likewise
as rochers also had an external
assessments undertaking
the assessment itself is undertaken by
the chartered Institute of Public
Finance and accountancy as to the
internal Awards of arrangements and
conformance to the public sector
internal audit standards the assessment
was as I said was completely in December
2022 for a review of documentation a
number of interviews of employees of the
internal audit team key statutory
officers within the council and the
chairman of the audit committee
the reviewer's opinion of the public
sorry the reviewer's opinion of the
internal audience was that we conformed
to the standards in all areas and this
can can be seen by the table provided
6.8 6.9 it sets out the areas where an
assessment was undertaken as you can see
from the table provided the internal
audit team was found to be conforming in
all areas
um so the opinion was that we conformed
in all areas and met the public sector
internal audit standards so there's not
much more to be said in terms of the
term the work of the team is fit for
purpose and conducted in the proper
manual in accordance with the standards
so we'll meet the standards and we fully
conform in all areas I'm quite happy to
take any questions around the assessment
members do you have any questions
councilor Gadson I don't actually have a
question I'd just like to congratulate
the team on all areas thank you
thank you thank you councilor Sharp
thank you uh Madam chairman
um under item five six
on page six eleven
there were two recommendations
one of which was fully implemented
whilst the other relating to the use of
specialized data analytics software
was considered but deemed not
appropriate for the service
Could you actually enlarge on why
yeah
absolutely
I will imply the use of data analytics
to to interpret the data in terms of the
work most of these Specialists
softwares is already implied within the
organization so basically what it
suggested is you undertake some data
matching and data analytics analytics of
the data you you audit much of those
controls are already in place so if we
look at say
um credited payments for example
when we pay something the inbuilt system
already checked whether that's a
duplicate invoice or we're paying the
same amount again so much the control is
already built into the software already
implied by us as an organization so what
they're saying is basically to undertake
additional checks in those areas but we
believe those checks have already been
performed so we don't want to undertake
work that we believe it's already be
undertaken or already built into the
systems implied by Roger Council so
there are a lot of processes out there
that already have built-in controls that
already imply as I say data analytics so
to undertake a further bit of work and
analytics is basically just repeating it
again so and we also participate in the
national fraud exercise so every two
years all our data is matched across a
number of local authorities so for us to
undertake another exercise on data
analytics well I believe it's already
been undertaken internally and also via
the national fraud initiative I think
this is basically
um money we don't need to spend because
to my mind those controls already
replaced and we're already doing that
work so it it wasn't a necessarily a
recommendation it is a view that I
should give consideration to implying
expensive data analytics into the work
of my team but it all it is essentially
is date imagined it might flag up areas
for subsequent review but my work
already does that so I was on my mind
not to basically imply expensive data
analytics
yeah that's a comprehensive answer and I
understand the rationale and thank you
thank you
are there any further questions
no
members there is one recommendation set
out at paragraph 9.1
that the results of the external quality
assessment be noted
is that noted members
members agenda item seven
internal audit plan and Charter 2023-24
again Mike Porter Chief audit executive
will introduce the report
thank you chair thank you again
the report provides for both the
internal audit plan for 2023-24 and also
the associated internal audit Charter
the role of internal audit is to provide
Assurance to both members and officers
as to the council's arrangements for
risk management government and internal
control so at the end of the year I'm
required to provide an opinion on the
council's arrangements for those areas
so the the audit plan is itself is
essentially a work program
identifying all the work that my team is
going to carry out in 2324 to arrive at
that audit opinion so we undertake a
number of audits during the course of a
year so I'm able to provide an opinion
at your end on the council's
arrangements as I said for risk
management
Governors and internal control
um in in producing the audit plan itself
I consult with officers of the council
senior management team in terms of the
areas they feel that we should be
looking at in 23 24 I also look at the
council's risk registers both the
corporate risks and the services in
terms of areas that I think are at risk
and therefore the areas they should look
at in addition to that I consult with my
peers so I speak to other heads of audit
from other local authorities in terms
what items are featuring in their audit
plans I also attend seminars with sifa I
also undertake a number of horizon
scanning in terms of what should
internal audit should be looking at what
is hot for internal audit so at the
moment the areas that are in all
internal audit teams are looking at is
cyber security that's high on people's
agenda at the moment so authorities are
a risk to fish and expectations and
mailware and things like that so cyber
security is something that is high up on
the list of all it's to be on the same
complain to an audit um for Russia we've
actually had a cyber security review
undertaken this year and as a part of my
annual report I will be reporting on the
results that cyber security review
so as I said so the audit plan itself is
sets out all the work I'm going to
undertake for rotary Council in 2324 to
arrive at opinion on the council's
arrangements good bad or indifferent
so that's the plan and I'll as I say I
consulted with a number of different
parties and putting that plan together
so it's not just my interpretation of
what I should be looking at I consult
wisely on it in terms of the charter
itself the charter is essentially the
terms of reference all it does is to set
out actually a helmet gun to undertake
my work so essentially it defines
internal what its purpose Authority and
responsibility and position within the
organization
the charter itself sets out the nature
of the work I'm going to undertake
and how internal reward it will help the
organization achieve its objectives
I'm quite happy to take any questions on
both items
members uh yes councilor Gadsden um I'm
not sure this is pertinent but when you
do a risk register at the moment our
investments
um what I'm concerned about is there
seems to be a run on certain Banks and
the financial picture of banking is a
little bit unstable is that something
you monitor under the risk
there would be a risk of regards to
basically Financial Risk within the
resurrection it would probably be a risk
more wider in financial resilience in
terms of actually how the council
operates and as I believe Rockstar
Council that's not actually invest it
doesn't have any debt or or basically
invested in I mean Tim might want to go
add something to this yes please Tim
foreign
and thanks Mike
um yes I guess this would be spotted um
in the context of the item on the agenda
here
um if there was an order of our treasury
management function because under
treasury management we look at our
investments and what we invest in and
what we don't invest in
and the and all of that information
about the parameters as to what we
invest in is contained in the treasury
management strategy which went along
with budget recently to through full
Council and we do a mid-year review and
then we do a retrospective on that as
well what I can say is that
along with all local authorities
um well all prudent local authorities
only invest in very safe Banks
it's I think still everyone is remembers
the Icelandic Bank times and that has
influenced people's decisions but in any
case
the number one priority for Investments
for Rochford and for local authorities
generally is the security
so they're not going to take any any
chances with with banks and they need to
they need to need to not be below a
certain standard as defined by the
finance industry for us to put any of
our money with with any Bank oh that's
fine I just want to make sure that we
they were reviewed as in light of the
financial situation with the banks at
the moment thank you
I can never guarantee that a major Bank
won't go fast but uh well I can give
assurance that we uh if anything on the
more prudent end of or what is an
already a prudent approach when it comes
to investing public money yes I
understand that thank you
any
councilor man
uh thank you chairman um I'll just want
to congratulate the team on actually
providing a very readable document
because a couple of years ago we had
some concerns about the the councilor's
understandings of the literature and uh
yeah and just thanks for that thank you
thank you councilman and I I second that
uh councilor Mrs Wilson
hello thank you and
as everyone probably knows this in my
first year on audit committee so you
know here comes the dove question really
um no such thing as a dance question oh
there is
um it's good to see um up front what
areas are going to be looked at this
year Mike which um is is quite good
because I've been in organizations where
you just get here's the report you've
not known has gone on so that's
brilliant
um can I just ask
when each of these um rests are looked
at audited
can we have or is it usual to have the
the full report not just the high level
report committee and to have this
beforehand so we can delve a bit deeper
than just the high level
findings that we've um or that I've seen
um so far this year
is that is that possible to do that
in terms of what goes to committee you
you get essentially the full findings
from that individual audit and also and
also on the distribution list for audits
it will go to the development portfolio
holder but essentially what you see is
the the true findings from each audit
and as part of the um
quality progress reports you get the
full extra full extract from the report
as presented so you are getting the full
findings from those audits in the
courtly Assurance report so so we
present each audit within that quarterly
Assurance report and you will see the
results
hey thank you um yeah I've just not seen
as much detail as I was expecting so
that's just me thank you okay thank you
counselor sharp yes and thank you
um in appendix a
there are two columns to the right
business plan priority and audit
priority
and I guess this is for clarification
um
does that signify in any way the impact
upon the council in terms of finances of
reputation I guess what I was expecting
to see was a a measure against the risk
register in terms of that color coding
and the the relative importance of a
breach of those controls
in those areas against the color-coded
method
my assessment of the work I need
undertake so all those ones highlight
audit Priority One well basically what
is I need to undertake to provide that
annual opinion year end
so so with priority two there are areas
that we need to look at but they're not
so important to that overall opinion
provided year end so basically with
priority two we're looking to basically
enhance the control framework and free
efficiencies in terms of operation but
they're not so important to me in
providing that overall opinion at your
end so for me I prioritize between one
and two the ones priority one of the
things I need to do because these are
key to to my assessment for council's
arrangements to our area service and
review areas where yes we would like to
undertaken a few of those
sorry uh some people here can't hear can
you pick the microphone up okay sorry
it was just that if it's recorded we
couldn't we wouldn't be able to pick it
up so it's quite important that you
speak into the mic thank you
um yeah so come up come back to what I
say the priority ones are things I need
to do undertake to provide that annual
opinion
um priority two of those service areas
where I'll be looking for controls
control weaknesses ways to improve the
service in terms of efficiency I don't
identify redundant controls but they're
not key from My overall opinion at the
year end
okay thank you for that um I mean would
it be a suggestion where you've got the
blue headings
to actually color code those so that we
know
the most important ones in terms of the
impact on the on the council
it's something I can look at in terms of
presentation yes yes
thank you chair
um it's an interesting point that
councilor sharp raises because
there are ways it's already true that
the
the council's approach to risk risk
management mitigating risks is woven
into the audit plan as well and it's
very transparent here because there are
specific corporate risks listed and how
that each audit relates to those
um what
um
some probably larger councils go as far
as is to compile a risk register and
then that directly influences what audit
resources go where so as risks rise then
that becomes the next audit plan that's
easier to do if you have a larger audit
team and you've you're much bigger local
Authority but there is I think scope for
showing more transparently the links
that are there but just below the
surface between risk risk management and
Audits and the audit plan and I think
that can become apparent as well if once
these audits start being completed and
reported back on if there's an audit in
an area that is a very high corporate
risk and the audit is coming back
there's not great Assurance then that
would be the sort of thing that this
committee might want to devote more
energy to they might even want to invite
the relevant director along to a meeting
to ask about so there are ways in which
the the this committee along with the
council more broadly with all of its
internal controls can ensure that those
areas of highest risk whether that be
impact or or likelihood are the ones
that receive the most focus when it
comes to internal controls and internal
audit is an important internal control
yes and I know in the past when we start
getting the results of of some of these
audits we do
um have you know
how how good it's doing so you know it
gets graded so we we see it much more
clearly when the results start coming in
assuming that's going to be done again
this year
um what what I would add is the plan is
flexible so so these the sort of the
audience at the start of the year and
the plan is subject to change so sort of
meteor September we take a fresh look at
the plan and look at the audits the
remainder of the year to see worth of
action they're still valid or whether
this new and emerging risks we need to
take account of So the plan although
it's set out for the 12-month period is
often subject to change and any change
to the plan is brought to this Committee
in terms of changes to the plan so it's
a flexible plan I like to
I have a view of what I'm going to do
for the year because the service
departments are saying to me what audits
are you going to do what you're going to
undertake and when you're going to
undertake them there are authorities
that have a a sort of only published a
plan for the first quarter they don't
publish what they're going to do for the
whole year they just set out what
they're going to do the first quarter so
if they have a role in list of audits
they might undertake there's several
ways to presenting it I can present a
plan in terms of the audits I think I
should do
for the whole of the year
highlight and it will be subject to
change or maybe subject to change or I
can present an audit plan that only
gives you audits for the first quarter
but I like to give a wider understanding
of the audience I'm likely to undertake
the whole year how I'm going to get my
opinion for the whole year but also
saying to you the plan is subject to
change and if higher risk areas come
along as Tim's highlighted that we will
undertake those those audit reviews so
it's a flexible plan depending on the
risk areas yeah I think I think it
always has been because we will get the
results of you know if something has
been completed or partially completed
and and as we go through the year we we
get information on that and if something
has taken priority over something else
before then we're informed of that
aren't we yeah as part of the the
quarterly um update the progress reports
that I provide you are informed in terms
of actually changes to the plan that
that will identify
what the audience are going to take out
or what new audits are going to put in
because of new emerging risk and these
are now higher priority than the audits
already in the plan so the plan plan
does change yeah yeah thank you
any further questions
oh one supplementary one thank you uh
and it's to Mike
um may I ask how frequently
you do an audit of the controls on the
purchase of of the insurances for the
council
um in looking at your insurance
Arrangements that that would depend on
essentially
um whether there have been any changes
to the process
um over the last few years we consider
that to be a high risk area
um we've not reviewed that area for a
number of years because we don't deem it
to be a high risk but that's not to say
if members feel that's an area we should
look at we could do consideration to
um we tend to look at things when we're
made aware of changes to the process or
there's concerns around that so it's not
it's not like a a rolling cycle or
rolling program our audience are
risk-based so if we understand there's a
risk or some new process has changed so
we we would look at it so because it's
risk-based it's not not like a cyclical
type approach towards anymore it's it's
a risk if someone identify a concern
with the process so if we're made aware
buyer from service department there's a
there's a risk of the process or there's
a change of operation or a change in
control it would be something we look at
so it's not something we're looking at
look at on a continuing basis
uh thank you for that I mean just by way
of example I mean if a Norse contractor
runs over somebody and and tragically
kills him that's a big liability against
an entity now presumably that will be
against Norse in the first first
instance but presumably RDC would have a
contingent liability it could be a large
sum of money
yeah the main contract that that big
Clause is within the contract in terms
of liability I mean it's not in like a
we need to undertake an audit of that
that area it's it's how the contract
itself in the first place in terms of
public liability and things like that so
that's when the contract's lit you make
those arrangements or have those
liabilities defined in the contract
and what you're saying is that they
don't change that frequently they're
fairly standard a roll over from year to
year
what I'm saying is basically in terms of
insurance policies and things like that
the contracts left with laws
with North and the contract will be
within within those terms of conditions
to the contract
but in terms of us auditing a process
what what I'm saying is we don't
necessarily audit a process use a year
in terms of insurance policies or or
purchase of insurance it's not something
we would look at continually and unless
we think there's a there's a risk in
terms of actually how we purchase
insurance or or our arrangements for
insurance have we ensured the right
thing so we might undertake an audit of
our insurance Arrangements in terms of
Are We ensuring the right things do we
have sufficient cover in terms of
insurance are we insuring all our assets
are all our assets covered so
we probably wouldn't undertake a review
of the procurement Arrangements but more
have we got sufficient cover for our
assets
thank you
no further questions
members we have two recommendations set
out at paragraph 10.1
I will move the first recommendation
and that is that the proposed audit plan
for 2023-24 be approved
do I have secondary
Council Myers thank you
can those members in favor please raise
their hands
that is unanimous thank you
the second recommendation is that the
internal Charter be noted
is that noted members
noted
thank you very much
and that concludes the business for this
evening and the meeting is closed at 8
00 pm thank you very much everybody for
attending
and good night and safety